what up space fam ghost in here from
anime outro and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest updates on demon
slayer including news on the spin-off
the demonstrator hinokami chronicles
game
and the most up-to-date info on the new
season so make sure to stay tuned for
this one
if you do enjoy these demonstrator
update videos let me know by smashing
that like button until it's blue and
dropping a hashtag demonstrhype
in the chat if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or else you will miss
future demonstrator videos and
updates when they drop also feel free to
check out my giant and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all the hashira
demon moons and much more link to that
is in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it it should come as no surprise that
demonstrator has been on fire over the
past couple of years according to an
article on comicbook.com in 2020
demonstrator sold a total of 82.34
million copies more than comicbook.com's
best
case estimate of the entire us comics
industry
so we're not saying all manga beat all
comics
we're saying one manga beat all comics
which is just insane to think about
and while demonstrate was the clear
winner among manga with its
record-breaking numbers in 2020 it was
also a big win for anime and manga in
general as
2020 was a new record for manga sales
it was manga's biggest year ever which
is great news for us
anime and manga fans the last record was
2007
when the big three naruto one piece and
bleach
and even death notes were all on the air
and the popularity of these big titles
obviously drove manga sales like crazy
so given all this it's not surprising
that demonstrator the king of manga
sales during manga's best sales year
got its first manga spin-off series and
i say
first because now that the floodgates
have been opened
and the mangaka is clearly cool with
others taking the reins for the story
i think more spin-off and sequel series
are bound to follow sooner or later
i'd love to see something like a my hero
academia vigilantes manga for demon
slayer obviously the idea would be for
gotoge the demonstrator creator
to come back for a sequel but according
to cbr.com in this case
natsuki hokami will be handling the
upcoming demonstrator spin-off series
the spin-off is inspired by the kimetsu
gao ken valentine
hen shorts which you can find on youtube
from this we can gather that it will
feature the characters we love
but put them in a school setting where
they'll probably undergo
some hilarious adventures seeing the
pillars as teachers
truly did bring a smile to my face and
will no doubt get plenty of memorable
moments from this series
that play on the quirks of specific
characters like yu's lack of popularity
according to anime news network this new
series will debut
on august 4th although it seems we'll
get a chibi style rather
than normal style in this case i
probably will check it out since it is
demonstrator and i love these characters
however i'm even more excited because as
i said one spin-off series can easily
lead to more
and this gives me hope that we'll get
one that is straight up taking place in
the same demonstrator world as the
original series
kind of like as i mentioned my hero
academia vigilantes
next let's look at the new demonstrator
video game that's coming out this year
i'm not a huge
gamer but i am excited about this one
and do plan to play it when it does drop
so follow the anime uproar twitch link
in the description if you want to be a
part of my first playthrough the
demonstrator hinokami chronicles game is
supposed to drop on october 15th
and should be released on ps4 ps5
xbox one and pc i'm kind of salty that's
not on nintendo switch but what can you
do
this game will let us play through the
earlier parts of the story already
covered in the anime series along with
the mugen train arc
it will also let us pick our favorite
characters and battle each other with
them which is my favorite feature in
these games because i
gozan love beating my brother animak in
video games
some of the playable characters will
include tanjiro
nezuko
and more some of which have not been
announced yet
i'm guessing we might miss out on some
of the other pillars though so that the
game doesn't spoil their unique powers
before we see them in the anime but time
will tell
i personally wouldn't care at all as
someone who read the entire manga but
some fans might not want to get spoiled
overall this game looks great so far and
it's the game i'm looking forward to
most right now
as a demon slayer stan finally let's get
to the new season aka second season that
will cover the entertainment district
arc as i pointed out before this season
will heavily feature the sound pillar
tangent
and upper moon 6. it's the best arc up
to this point in the story in my opinion
and since ufo table is animating it
again i have no doubt it will be
straightfire
but when's the release date that's the
big question they have confirmed that it
would be in 2021
but haven't given us an official
specific date as of yet however there
was new information revealed
interestingly enough that demonstrator
season 2 will reveal more new
information on july 13th
which since we're well into 2021 i do
expect will include the exact release
date of the first episode
of season 2. it's fine to make an
announcement about an announcement but
the fact that they're hyping up this
announcement must mean it's something
big
comicbook.com has cited an update from
yahoo japan that has narrowed the
release date to october 2021 which would
make a lot of sense in my opinion
we know from the past that demonstrator
likes releasing different stuff
in tandem with each other to build the
hype we saw this when special then
goku's stories were dropped to hype up
the demon sarah mugen train movie
as i said the game is set to drop on
october 15th and if i go to pre-order
the complete demonstrator box set
amazon tells me it will be released on
october 5th 2021
i believe the box set will release on
the same day as season 2 or
before because that way they can
capitalize on all the hype of the season
by getting people to buy the box set
so yeah hopefully we'll get an exact
date on the 13th announcement but i
believe
mid-october is most likely keep in mind
that yahoo japan article is not an
official demonstrator announcement and
thus it could turn out to be false
but sometimes info does leak so i
wouldn't be surprised if they got wind
of the rumored release date beforehand
but anyways that is it for this one i
enjoy doing these demon slayer update
videos every so often to keep you guys
updated on all the exciting demonstrator
related stuff that's happening in the
world i'll also add that mugen train has
now grossed over 40 billion yet in japan
while the second highest film spirit
away is at less than 32 billion
the demonstrator movie alone blew every
other movie
out of the water in terms of the
japanese box office
anyways if you did enjoy this video and
want to keep the demon sayer updates
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that
like button until it's blue and drop a
hashtag demonstrate hype
in the chat if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demon slayer videos and updates when
they drop
keep in mind if there's a video you're
burning up to see leave the suggestion
for that topic in the comments of this
video and i may make it soon
also feel free to check out my giant and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos on all the hashira
demon moons and much more link to that
is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord wigo himself alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grata but they have the al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted she the
spike eight two two seven
emperor otaku spidey life tennelle
tungsten tarkis fake buddhist cody
hebert and monkey d
quilly and our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh the red haired
raven
angel crews rathu and deiora very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks joanne garcia
ted no ted fatboy games corey mcgowan
and soul rise slice and dice thank you
all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar or you can
become a channel member here on youtube
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description
if you're interested and as i mentioned
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way to support us you
can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you